こんにちは！　はじめしゃちょーです！
今回は！！！！！！
もう、俺一人でいなりずし100個食べようと思います！
ふんっ
ナゲットよりちょっと大きいかな。。。。。
よくよく考えたらナゲットより少し大きい気もするんですけど
それでもやはり、あの僕最近
結構大食いとかあの…動画外でやってるんで
胃の大きさが比較的に大きくなってると思います
そしてお肉以外のものばっかり食べてるんで
米好きなんで
たぶんこれぐらいの、いなり寿司だったらパッと食べられると思います！！
ちなみに、くら寿司で買って来ました
いやマジ余裕っすよ！
まってこれいなり寿司って一個何キロカロリーなんだろう...
二貫で一皿なんですよ
たぶんこれ、一皿分のあれなんで
142×50で
今腹ペコ状態なので、割といけると思います！
いただきます！！！！
稲荷寿司、僕、あの
お魚があまり得意じゃないので
たまご、稲荷、サーモンぐらいをよく食べまーす
おいしそうですねぇ
いただきます
【音楽】
全然余裕です
どんどんいきましょう！！
【音楽】
10個目！！
10個食べてみた感想なんですけども
稲荷が甘いのでこうなんか
酢飯で食欲がそそられてでもう
僕は止まることを知りません
どんどんいきます！！！！
【音楽】
はい、20皿食べてみて思ったことなんですけれど
なんか触感がやばい
スポンジをこう...噛み続けてる感じというか...
なんか...こう...なんなんでしょうね......
つらいです(迫真)
がんばります！
【音楽】
(箸でリズムをとるはじめ)
お稲荷さ～ん許して～
すごい...なんだこれ
【音楽】
はい、というわけで
え～、４０
え、違うw全然40も食ってねぇやw
25個　四分の一を食べたところなんですけども
すいません........うぅ.......
むりだぁむりだぁぁ
あぁぁぁーーーーーだれかぁぁぁぁーーーーーーあぁぁぁ
だれかぁぁぁぁぁーーー
（ヒョイ）
た）水くさいっすよはじめさん
た）俺にもその稲荷食わせてくだせぇや
は）たなっち！！
た）早く呼んでくんねぇかなって思ってた
は）いやほんっとにすごいよ
は）はいというわけですみません
は）一人だとちょっと案の定無理だったんで
は）二人で100個食べれるように頑張っていきたいと思います
は）いや違う！俺も食べます！！
は）じゃあ俺こっち食べるよ
た）わかりました
た）ふふっ　　は）ふっはっは
た）あぁー！！
た）え！おいしい！！
100いけそうw
【音楽】
は）もぉ～むりだぁ～
は）ね～ぇ　もぉ～む～り～～
【音楽】
は）味に飽きるんですよ味に！
は）同じ単調な味が続くと
は）それでちょっと今僕やられてるとこがあるんで
は）ちょっと醤油なり、なんなり使って
は）味変して攻めていきます
は）ありがとうございっした..
【音楽】
た）いや、これはきついわ...
は）いやたぶん、ナゲットよりきつくない？
た）へへっ　　は）はっはは
【音楽】
は）ふぇっぶっしゅん！！
た）やりやがったww
は）ごめんね、わざとじゃないんだよw
た）わざとじゃねぇ奴こんなのやってこねぇからw
【音楽】
30個食べて思ったことは
は）スポンジ食べる？　食べないでしょ？
た）うん
は）俺食べてんだよ今
た）ふふっ
は）スポンジをｗ
【音楽】
た）えふっ！！
は）おーーい！！
た）あ、ぇ、ぇ、え、え！！　やだやだ！！
た）お願い！！！！
た）ほんとにw
た）むりむり
【音楽】
は）でも俺やばい！後13個だ
は）ちゃんと終わって、そっちいくから
は）絶対ここは食いますから、何が何でも
た）頼りになるぜ
は）（やべぇ...言っちまった）
は）（もう後には引けねぇ...）
は）（終わったぁ...)
は）あっ
は）半分いってる！
は）半分切ったんでこのままちょっといってみます！！
【無】
【音楽】
た）いやまじでツレェこれ
た）いやこれ超ツラいっすわ
た）多いんだよ（泣）
は）ぶふっ
た）ここだけ
は、た）ふふっはっはっはw
た）いやでもマジもうすぐじゃないすか　すげぇ
【音楽】
た）はぁ！
た）ふぅ！
は）ふふぅw
【音楽】
た）いやすごすぎる...
は）というわけで50個は食べれました
は）目標の100個には全然届かないんで
は）ここからはなるべくサポートにまわります
は）二人で100個食おう！！
た）わかりました
は）最初はグーじゃんけんぽん！
は）あいこでしょ！
は）あいこでしょ！！
は）最初はグーじゃんけんぽん！
た）へっへw
た）くっそぅ
た）んでしょ
た）えぇ～
は）どぅぇ～
は）んっ！　　はぁぁぁぁ！！！
は）んっ！！　　あぁぁぁぁ！！　　うぉえ！！
カンカンカンカンカ～ン